Good morning class. Today we do the
theory
of
everything.
So very quickly I will explain to you
what science tells us about where we
came from, who we are, and where we're
going. So
as you may know, it all started with a
big bang.
Okay, the big bang.
So, in the beginning there was a massive
ball of energy and then it exploded.
Okay. And because of this explosion,
it would create stars and planets and
black holes and solar systems.
And that's how the universe was created
through the big bang.
Then we had the earth and on earth life
evolved starting with
um plants and sea life and then we had
um lizards, mammals and then we got to
humans. Okay. So evolution
the thing about evolution that's very
important to understand is that it's all
about m mutation.
So the genes will randomly mutate
and then those genes that are best
adapted to the environment will survive.
Okay. And this is idea of the survival
of the fittest introduced to us by
Charles
Darwin.
Okay. And that's how we came to dominate
the planet because we are the fittest
because we're able to work together
because we had language which allows us
to
store knowledge and pass it on to future
gener generations to accumulate new
technology. Okay. So that's the theory
of evolution.
Now we get to the human mind, right? The
human mind is unique in the universe. Um
it allows us to communicate with each
other. It allows us to imagine things.
It allows us to be creative.
And so neuroscience
teaches us that our brains what we our
brains do is we filter experiences
into memories.
Now if you take psychology you will know
that there's long-term memory and
short-term memory. Short-term memory is
just what you have today. Long-term
memory is what stays in you. Okay. So
what the brain does is that it
differentiates between shortterm and
long-term. And then this long term is
stored into a database of memories and
it's divided according to your emotions.
Okay? Happy,
sad, angry, scared. Okay? So there's a
rainbow of emotions and all your
memories are stored according to the
different emotions inside your brain,
the database of your brain. And from
this you are able to create an identity.
Identity is basically an understanding
of who you are, your place in the world,
and how you should best navigate the
world. Okay. So the idea of identity now
what you also learn in psychology is it
is possible for you to create many
different identities.
So in a school you're a student at home
you're a child at work you're an
employee. Okay. And all these identities
put together is called a world view.
And you can understand this as your
personality.
Okay. All right. So, this is all that
science knows. I mean, this is pretty
simple, but this is what science tells
us about where we came from, who we are,
where we're going. Now, there are three
distinct characteristics about the
Islam.
Okay. The first is that this is all
random.
Okay. Okay, this is really important
because before we understood this as
design. Okay, before we believe that
there was a god. Now we believe there's
no god. All this is just random. That's
the first thing I need you guys to
remember. Second thing I need you guys
to remember is that it's all material.
Material.
Before we understood the universe as
spirit mainly spirit but now we
understood it as mainly material things
that we can see and touch. We cannot see
it. We cannot touch it. We cannot
measure it. It does not exist. The third
characteristic is that it is emergent.
Emergent which is basically means bottom
up.
You have like these particles they
become atoms then the atoms become
matter. they become
stuff and then we become chairs or
people. Okay, it's all emergent. And so
these are the three major
principles of our world view today and
you should have learned most of this in
science class.
Now
there's a problem with all these
theories.
All right? Right. So, I'm going to go
over them one by one and I want I want
to make sure you follow along, okay?
Because what I will do now is I will
show you the problems, the deficiencies,
the flaws in all these theories.
Okay. So, let's start with the
big bang. Now if it is true that
the universe started off with a big bang
and it just expands slowly
then
it should it should expand linearly.
Okay. But what we see is this. First of
all the universe it expands weirdly.
Okay. It's more like this.
So as it expands different parts move
faster than other parts. That makes no
sense.
Also, certain galaxies, okay, galaxies
move faster than other galaxies.
This makes no sense either.
So,
the way that astronomers have explained
away these
statical problems is to introduce a new
concept called dark energy.
And dark energy is most of the universe.
It's it's like at least 80%. Some
scientists believe it is 90%. So most of
the universe is composed of dark energy.
And of course you're like what is dark
energy? And the answer is we don't know.
Now dark energy sounds like we don't see
it. That's how it is. It's we don't know
what it is. And quite honestly it's
cheating. Okay. So let me give an
example. Let's just say you take a math
test and the teacher asks you 19887 plus
25 and your answer is 20. Okay, that's
obviously wrong, right? So your teacher
says this is wrong. And then you say,
"Oh, I know how to fix this." Plus
dark energy.
Problem solved.
Okay, this is like literally what
cosmologists are doing with dark energy.
We don't know what it is,
but they say it must be there because
otherwise
we cannot explain
these statistical inconsistencies in our
measurements and modeling. And then of
course you're like, well, why don't you
just say that the Big Bang theory is
wrong? And they're like, well, we could
say that the problem is we don't have a
better model. Well, in fact, there is a
better model. The better model is there
are different big banks. Okay? So, if
you just assume that there are different
big banks, well, this helps us
understand
what's going on better. But then the
question then is, wait a minute, there
are multiple big bangs. Why are there
multiple big bangs?
Okay. So, our current system of
understanding the universe simply does
not work. And the problem is that it's
become a paradigm,
a story that is accepted by most
scientists and they refuse to budge on
this issue. Okay? But I'm telling you
right now that this system is clearly
problematic and it could be wrong. Okay.
So, that's a problem with
um the big bang. Now, let's move on to
evolution.
Okay. Evolution.
Now,
in theory, evolution does work and it
works for most animals except when it
comes to human beings. Okay? Because
that the the idea of evolution is
gradual progress.
But we don't know how we went from the
ape, okay, to the human.
We share with the ape other monkeys
99.9% of DNA. But we don't know why
we're so different from the ape. Okay,
that's the first problem. Second problem
is humans have been around for for about
200,000
years. Okay, that's a long long time. We
only have maybe 50,000 years
of history.
So where do the other 100,000 150,000
years go? We don't know.
Okay. So this is also another huge
problem with the theory of evolution.
The third problem is
according to evolution there should be
many different types of human beings.
But in fact there's only one homo
sapiens. Now what scientists will tell
you is well before there were different
species the n theanthodol the cromagnet
and then gradually homo sapiens took
them over
and that's and you can believe that but
it's problematic because according to
evolution there should be many many
different types of humans okay maybe
some with six fingers some with three
eyes like animals
Okay. So the lack of diversity in the
human species, it's a it's it doesn't
really fit into the evolution model.
Okay. All right. So that's problem with
evolution. The real problem is with the
human mind. Okay. So let's go over some
of the problems. All right. So with
neuroscience, what they teach you is
that what the world view does that's
very important is that it filters
memories. Okay? The reason why is every
day you're absorbing a lot of
experiences. Your if your brain were to
absorb all the experiences, your brain
will explode because there's too much
information to process. Therefore, your
world view pro processes different
experiences. It differentiates between
experiences that are important and
experiences that are not important. And
experiences that are important of course
goes into your long-term memory.
The problem with this is how about
babies?
In theory, babies should not have a
worldview. They should not have a
personality. But if that's the case,
then how do they process memories? How
do they know what memories to store?
What memories not to store?
Okay. The other thing is that I have
three kids and I can tell you that
they're all distinct personalities. It
seems as though they were born with a
world view.
And then the question then is where does
this come from?
Your eye color, your hair, your height
comes from your parents DNA, right? So
does your is your personality from your
parents DNA? Probably not. Okay. Just
ask yourself, am I a composition of my
parents' personalities? You're not.
You're a different person than your
parents. So, this is a huge problem with
this model.
Where does the personality come from?
And why is it embedded in us from the
very first day? Okay.
What's more problematic is how we think
consciousness.
We do not have currently a model for how
we think. In fact, if you study
neuroscience, you will find there are a
lot of gaping holes in our understanding
of the brain.
For example, we do not know where the
brain
stores memory.
That's very unusual because a memory is
a building block of everything but we
don't know in the brain where it is
stored. Yeah.
>> Isn't that hypocus?
>> Excuse me.
>> No. The hippoc campus.
>> No.
>> No, it's not. we we we don't know where
where it's stored. There are certain
things this that we know where it's
stored. For example, we know where maybe
language is stored. We know where faces
are stored. Okay? So maybe the phases
are stored in the hippoc campus, but we
don't know where memory is stored. Okay?
So what we say is the entire brain
stores memories. But that's another
saying we don't know where it's stored.
All right. So the other thing is that
our current model of the brain
it's like a city okay think of the brain
as a city and what makes the brain work
are the roads or what we call the
synapses when they hit each other it has
it creates electricity and that's where
we think
that um how thought is generated.
Okay. But this is problematic because
um we think a lot. Okay. So let me give
you an example of this to clarify.
Now in science class you're taught the
scientific method.
Okay. What's the scientific method?
Well, you do research.
You create a hypothesis from the
research and then you create an
experiment to test out the hypothesis
and then you have data and then you make
observations
and then you refine the hypothesis.
Okay? And this is
what we believe a way to model the act
of thinking.
And you're taught this in every class,
even in in English class, right? You do
research, then you create an outline,
right? The outline has a thesis with
three evidence, right? And then you
write it out, write a draft,
you edit it,
and you repeat the process. Okay? This
this is what you're taught in school.
Okay?
I'm going to say something that shocks
that that will shock you. Okay?
This is what you you're taught in
school. This is what you believe works.
But as someone who is much older than
you are, as someone who actually thinks
for a living, who teaches for a living,
who writes for a living, I'm going to
tell you how you actually think is a
complete opposite.
Okay? So what happens is you actually
you actually
think or imagine the story or the idea
to begin with. Okay?
And then you start working backwards
to create the process.
You're taught in school it's a process
that creates the the idea. What I'm
telling you is that in reality, it's the
idea that creates the process.
Okay? So, let me give you an example of
this. If you look at every major scient
discovery, it all came to the person in
a dream or when he was
or it sort of popped into that person's
head. Okay? It's just think of a light
bulb light bulb popping up. Okay? So, an
example is Albert Einstein. Albert
Einstein created his theory relatively
not in a laboratory,
not by
um doing research with other scientists,
but simply by sitting in a patent office
every day and just daydreaming. And then
boom, the idea came to his head. He's
like, "Okay, now I have this idea. Now
what he's going to do is go back and
look for the evidence to support his
idea."
>> Yes.
>> Hypothesis.
Okay. Um, is a hypothesis the idea?
Okay. No, the hypothesis is the
assumption.
Okay. What? Okay. What what I'm trying
to tell tell you is this. What I'm
trying to tell you is the idea or the
final product comes first. Then you go
backwards.
Okay? And you create the draft. Then you
create the outline. then you do the
research.
Okay, now I know this sounds weird, but
let me give you more examples.
James Watson came up with the double
helix model of DNA.
How he did this was he spent years and
years working to figure out how DNA
worked. And then boom, one day he had a
dream of a staircase, a double
staircase. And he's like, maybe that's
the
model I need to use. And then he start
to do more research and he discovered,
hey, this works. Okay, but the question
then is how did that get into his head?
Okay, let me give you another example.
Um, I write books and I've written three
novels.
Um, and you won't believe this, okay?
But but my wife is here and and like she
knows how I work. You would think that
when you write a book, you would spend
every day at the at the desk and um read
books, take notes, and then transform it
into a book, right? I don't do that.
What I do is I lie in bed and I might
play some video games or I might read a
book. Okay? I get up, I walk to the park
and I come back and I have all these
ideas and I write down all these ideas
over one hour, two hours on the
computer. Okay? Then I'm exhausted. I've
run out of ideas and I'm like, "Okay,
tomorrow what am I going to do if I have
no ideas? I can't write anymore." But
what happens is the next day I get up
and I have new ideas and I write it back
and I I write it down again. Okay? So
it's not like I am generating these
ideas. It's more like I'm receiving
these ideas.
If you watch me actually watch me work,
it is almost impossible
to think that I actually do any work
because I'm always like lying around or
walking around or daydreaming. Okay, my
wife tells me that when I write or when
I work, it's like I'm possessed. I'm
possessed by something. Okay, meaning
like I actually I don't see anything and
I really don't know what other people
are doing because I don't care.
I don't care because I'm focused on my
work. Okay? Also, I'll give you another
example. The way I teach now when you
see me teach, you think, oh, you must
have a script. You must have outlined
the class. I don't do that. I have a
conception. I have a framework in my
head. I come to class and I teach. How
do I teach? I watch your observations.
I watch your facial expressions and
based on your responses, I then start to
flesh out the framework and how how and
and how do I do that? Because I'm always
accessing a higher force and I'm
receiving this information that I can
then articulate to you in class. And
that's why if you have been with me for
a long long time, 10 years, you will
know I've never taught the same class
ever. You can go on YouTube and watch
all my videos. I teach this class
different each time because each time
what I'm doing is I'm channeling a
higher force and bring it to you.
But it is a conversation. It's a
dialogue. It's no different from reading
a book or seeing a great painting. Okay?
Each experience is unique because when
you because a painting or the book, it's
almost like a platform for you to
experience the divine or higher power.
Okay? When you read a great book, that's
literally what you feel. You feel as
though you are in conversation with the
universe. And this book is really a
portal into the universe. Okay? If you
read a good great book, I'm not sure if
if you had if you had uh read a good
great book. Okay? So, if you want to
really be creative, you have to trust
the universe. If you really really want
to destroy your creativity, you follow
this system. Okay? So, what I'm telling
you, and that's I know this this is
going to be weird, but school, it
destroys your creativity because it
teaches you a process that does not
work. No scientist in the history of
humanity has ever come up with a great
idea using the psyic method.
I guarantee you, they've all came up
with a great idea through their
imagination, through their intuition, by
channeling the divine. Okay, that's
every single scientist including um
Einstein, Newton. Uh yes,
>> I wait sorry. Can you speak to
Okay, so I agree with what you're
saying, but I personally I I I think
scientific method is more like how
people how these inspirational ideas are
being presented to others.
>> Oh yes, good point. Exactly. That's
that's exactly correct. Okay. So, I use
static method in order to convince other
people that I'm correct. You're
absolutely correct because if I told
people, oh, I had a dream. Well, like is
that convincing? Okay. So, the sc method
is a way for for us to communicate and
spread ideas. You're absolutely correct.
Okay. But as I say, you will never ever
have a great discovery by following a
seic method. You have to have an
inspiration and then use the same method
to explain your inspiration to other
people. Okay.
Yeah.
And another thing, sorry. And another
thing is that I I think how people
absorb ideas or
look like how how how you wrote a book
is by based on your at least some some
of the points are based on your
experience because let's just say a
person has born and he never like he has
no knowledge and he has no experiencing
on uh anything and I don't see the
possibility for him to just observe this
energy energy out of nothing.
>> Okay, you're exactly correct. Yes. And
I'll explain this as we move on. Okay.
All right. But I want to show you
there's lots of issues with um how the
SIC method is taught in school. Okay.
So, but but but are you guys clear? All
right. But but but that's a good point.
Let me continue. All right. So, let me
continue.
We have
so much evidence
that we communicate with a higher power
all the time. All right. So, so let's go
over some of the evidence. Okay. The
first piece of evidence is
nearde experiences
ndees.
Near-deaf experiences
are
um when you almost die, okay? or you're
dead for like 10 seconds or 10 minutes,
who knows? But there are thousands, tens
of thousands of these testimonies on
YouTube and they all say the same thing.
When they die, they see a tunnel and at
the tunnel there's a light that draws
them. Okay, they go and then suddenly
they are high up and they feel
tremendous love, peace, forgiveness,
compassion. It's all good.
And then they submit to a life review.
They have a chance to reflect on their
entire life. They can see all the pain
they caused. They can see all the good
they've done in the world.
And
then they're asked by a higher force and
it's like God or an angel but like there
are different interpretations. Okay.
Do you want to go back? And they always
say yes, I need to go back. Why? Because
I need to tell people about my
experience. and they come back extremely
changed people and again these are
people who don't know each other
and maybe before they were atheists or
just scientists but once they have these
experiences it changes them forever.
Okay. So, near-death experiences, we
have prompts explaining why this is the
case. Second is the is the idea of
psychedelics.
Okay.
Okay. Psychedelics. So, throughout human
history, every culture has had has used
psychedelics because psychedelics were a
way for shamans or priests to access the
divine.
And what's really interesting is when
you use a certain type of psychedelic,
you end up seeing the same images
regardless of who you are. Okay? And
that's why
civilizations
throughout human history,
what's amazing is if you go back to the
ancient past and you look at different
civilizations in different parts of the
world, they have very similar statues
and paintings. Okay? So what's a very
common motif is that you have a cosmic
serpent. For whatever reason, every
early civilization has worship a serpent
or serpent. The serpent is a very
important part of their culture. And
it's possible that when they're
psychedelics and they're meditating,
they see a serpent talking to them and
they see that as the serpent of life.
Okay. And also what's really interesting
is the serpent. It's almost it looks
like the DNA,
right? Okay. So that's really really
interesting. Okay. Um meditation
when people meditate when you go up to a
higher
uh dimension you you end up you end up
having the same experience of
psychedelics and they do have
experiences
also great books
I myself have never done psychedelics I
obviously can't go back in the past and
study these civilizations I never had a
near near-death experiences but I've
read Dante
I've read Milton. I've read Homer. I've
studied them very, very closely. And it
what's amazing to me is they say the
same things.
When Dante in his Divine Comedy, when he
describes the universe, when he
describes God, when he describes the
heavens, it's almost as though he's
describing a near-death experience, even
though we have absolutely no evidence
that Donn himself had a near-death
experiences.
Okay, so this is shocking.
Okay. So, there's a lot of evidence that
there's a higher force beyond us. So,
the spirit world does exist. Again, I
can't prove it exists, but a lot there's
a lot of evidence to suggest it does
exist. Okay. So, now the question then
is if our current model of reality
doesn't really work, what is
another possibility? Okay. And in this
class, I'm not trying to tell you what
is true, but I'm just trying to present
to you new possibilities. So what I'm
going to do now is I will present to you
a new possibility of how of how reality
is structured. Okay? All right. So to
begin, let's talk about Kant. Emanuel
Kant was the greatest philosopher who
ever lived. The most influential
philosopher who ever lived because he
introduced
us the idea that we are not observers of
reality. We are participants in reality.
All right. So let me explain what he
means
for Kant. There's a nana. The nana just
means reality that is outside of us. The
things in themselves. What he tells us
is we can never know. No the nana. We
can never know this reality. Why?
Because whenever we see reality we
filter it using time and space. Okay. So
time and space do not exist outside of
us. They are part of us. We use time and
space in order to interpret reality in a
way that allows us to make sense of it.
Okay. So the nina for time and space
becomes the phenomena
and that's all we see the phenomena the
things that are to me not the nana the
things in themselves. Okay. And so we
imagine reality we hallucinate reality.
Okay, but of course this creates three
problems. Okay, the first problem is uh
what is the nomena? The second problem
is
why do we have these filters time and
space? The third problem is how do how
can we guarantee that what I see is the
same as what you see? Because if reality
is a subjective experience,
then in theory, everyone should see it
differently. But we all see it the same.
Okay. So why is that? So these are the
three problems. And so what happens is
that Hegel comes along. Okay. Hegel
another German philosopher. He explains
the idea of the gist. So what he's
saying is that the nana, it's really the
spirit world. It's the gist. And when
you do this, it solves all three
problems. Okay? The nana you can never
access because it's beyond us.
It's a gist that gives us time and space
and as a result because it's all coming
from one source we see the world in the
same way.
Okay. All right. So
this sounds complicated but but but let
me now use quantum mechanics to explain
what this means. Okay. Let's let's talk
about quantum mechanics.
Okay. So in science class you're taught
the neo
bore model of the atom. Okay it's a
simple model. You have the nucleus and
then around the nucleus you have these
electrons that orbit the nucleus. Okay
you taught this in physics class.
>> Um if you are in more advanced physics
you were taught that it's actually an
electron cloud.
>> Why? Because we never know for sure what
electrons are. So we can only know the
probability of where they are in orbit.
Okay? So it's called electron cloud. And
this is what you're taught in school.
When you go to university, you're you
will be taught this is completely and
utterly wrong.
Why? Because this assumes that these
atoms are matter. They're solid. But in
reality, if you go deep enough, you will
find that they are actually just
vibrations, what we call quantum fields.
And they are just vibrations. And what
the electron really is is an
intersection
of these quantum fields.
Also
these quantum fields can always exist in
two states. The first is as a wave. The
second is as a particle.
Okay?
And we can only know if it's a wave or a
particle by observing it. And this is
what what's called a wave function
collapse.
In other words,
all of nature is vibrational. It's
energy. And it's only when we observe
it, when you interact with it, that
becomes something solid that we can see
and measure and touch. Okay. It's called
a wave function collapse.
Okay.
So, this is complicated. So a a um
physicist named Erns Schroinger, he
creates a thought experiment called
Schroinger's cat. Okay, you may have
heard of it. Schroinger's cat.
And so imagine a box and inside is a cat
and then the cat in inside the box is
also some toxic chemicals that may or
may not break. If it breaks, the cat
dies. If it doesn't break, the cat the
cat's still alive. And what Shinju
teaches us is that when the box is
unopened, we can never know the state of
the cat. It's only when we open it can
we know it's dead or alive. But before
then, it's both dead and alive. Okay,
that's simple. You understand? But then
another physicist introduced a new
concept called the friend experiment or
Wner's friend.
And this is more complicated because he
says, "Okay, if you are the
experimentter and you open the box, you
now know the state of the cat, but what
if you're a friend? Okay,
you're you don't see the box.
You're outside the laboratory.
When the experiment opens the box,
does the wave function collapse?" And
the answer is it does not.
Okay, it does not. And what this is
telling us is there is no objective
reality that exists outside of you. When
the experimenttor opens the box, the
wave function collapses for him. But
does that collapse for the observer and
for anyone else? We have to open the box
ourselves in order to see if the cat is
alive or dead.
Okay. But what if this person tells us
the answer is it still doesn't collapse.
We have to participate in the reality
ourselves. And what this is saying,
okay, this is hard to understand is that
everyone lives in his or her own
reality.
Everyone has a unique universe onto
himself or herself. And that's what
quantum mechanics teaches us.
Okay. All right. So now let's try to
based on all this okay quant and quantum
mechanics create a theory of reality.
Okay. So what's important to understand
is that
all everything are just vibrations.
Okay. That's all it is. It's vibrations.
Yeah.
But I thought like quantum mechanics can
only be applied on quantum whereas we
are
a macro creature that is not like
>> yeah that is correct but the quantum
mechanics is the is the basis of reality
right okay so we are so everything are
just vibrations
now what happens is that what we need to
understand is that if it's vibrations if
it's energy it's also information. Okay,
does that make sense? All right.
So, what our brains do is our brains are
not independent. Our brains connect to
the universe. Okay? So, as the universe
is vibrating, we're receiving
information and then through our
experiences.
Okay? This vibration allows us to turn
it into memories.
You understand? We're taking this um
vibrational information. We're taking
our experiences. We're combining to
memories. Now, this is really important.
The memories now go back to the
vibrational force. So, our memories are
connecting to the universe and they're
being stored in the universe. They're
being imprinted in the universe. It's an
imprint.
And this and of of course this is no
different from the internet right
on the computer whatever you write is
being stored on the internet. So
whatever you do is going to change the
internet
and you receive information from the
internet. Okay? So you're participating
in the internet and you're part of the
internet. Okay? And the same thing is
happening here.
Okay? So everything's vibrational. If
it's vibrational, it's information. We
we turn we take the information and we
combine with the experiences turn into
memories. The memories then go back to
the universe. And so it's as as it's
it's as though we can implant ourselves
into the universe.
Okay.
Now this is hard to understand.
So what we've done is every single
culture has turned this knowledge into a
story that is easy for people to
understand.
Okay. So, I'm going to tell you the
story. And this story, this framework,
I'm actually using Dante. Okay. All
right. Dante, what what does Dante tell
us about the universe? Okay. Just the
Monad,
the one God, who knows? Okay. But it's
the source of everything.
And so what he does is he vibrates,
>> he emanates, he thinks, he breathes. And
this creates vibrational force right and
this vibrational force creates new
forces called diads. Diads are peers.
And when the peers come together and
vibrate they create new things. Okay. So
this is how creation happens through
vibration through the combination of
different um forces. Okay. Now what's
important to understand is that as the
dimensions go lower the frequency
decreases. So at high it's really fast
right it's like ah okay when it goes low
it becomes low frequency oh okay
and eventually you get a point where
matter can be created okay so this is
spirit
this is matter and this is the world
that we live in
okay so now the question then is why is
a universe set up in this way and it has
to do with the fact that the universe,
the monad strives for newness, for
imagination, for freshness. The problem
though is that in the spirit world,
everything is perfect. Everything is
eternal. Everything is immutable. And so
by definition, you can feel no pain. You
cannot suffer. You cannot make any
mistakes. Therefore, you can you cannot
have any new experiences. Therefore you
cannot you cannot have have any
imagination.
So we humans exist in order to solve
this problem. We humans are corporal
which is which all it just means is we
have bodies. Okay. If you have bodies
you go you get old, you bleed, you get
hurt, you fall down. Okay, you feel
um anger you feel hate. But this allows
us to have an imagination.
And the imagination allows the universe
to grow, to expand,
to vibrate. Okay, that's our function to
have experiences that are new, which
expands the consciousness of the
universe. Universe itself is
consciousness. All right, so
for this system to work, there have to
be some guiding principles to this
universe. The first and most important
principle is the principle of free will.
Without free will, this system cannot
work. If if you are if if you do what
you're supposed to do,
you can't have imagination. Okay? So,
you have to disobey. You have to make
your own choices. You have to make your
own mistakes. And this is what allows
the universe to imagine.
Okay? But the problem then is if you
have free will, how do you know you're
doing good? How do you know you're doing
evil? And the answer is the idea of
love.
Okay? So the monad is the totality of
love. We are a part of the monad.
Okay? We're part of the monad. And so
there's a spark of the monad in us
called love. And so when we do good, we
feel good because the love, the spark is
growing in us. And it's almost like a
magnet. Okay? We want to return to the
monad. And so we do good because it
makes us feel good and allows us to
return to the monad.
But sometimes because we live in a world
of free will, we make mistakes. Okay, we
might hurt someone or we might be or we
might traumatize someone in which case
we feel anger and then this becomes a
vicious cycle. Okay, so now there's
another system set up to ensure we don't
get trapped by our hate and this system
is called death.
Okay,
in this system death is released.
It prevents us from forever making
mistakes because you could have a
terrible life, right? But it's okay
because then you go die, you go back,
you go back into the universe and now
you can observe everything that you did.
Okay? You can see all the pain you've
caused. You can see all the good that
you've done. And so you become wiser and
you come back and you live another life.
And again, you can make the same
mistakes over and over, but you can also
improve. Okay.
Now the other thing to remember about
the system is that it's our choice
whether you create love or hate. Now
love goes back to the monad.
But what happens when you create hate?
Well, you need to store it somewhere. So
it goes into lower dimensions. Okay.
Hate.
All right. So we create new dimensions
through hate, through anger, through
fear, through bad emotions that cannot
return the spirit world because the
spirit world is perfect. And so this is
called hell
and this called heaven.
Okay? And this is how the universe is
set up.
Okay? So I'm just taking the literal
reality and turning to the metaphorical
reality which becomes the basis of all
early religions.
Okay. So there are different metaphors
that we can use to understand
uh this system. But let's look at let's
look at look at um one from Hinduism and
one from Dante. Okay.
So in Hinduism there's a metaphor that's
very powerful and the metaphor is that
in the
house of the god Indra Indra is one of
the most powerful gods of India
there's all these pearls
that float. Okay. And what do what do
pearls do? They reflect other pearls.
And what happens is this. Because
there's a spark in us, if one of our
sparks grows bright, all the other
pearls grow bright as well. Okay? So,
literally, because God is inside of you,
because there's a spark inside of you,
because you're capable of love, when you
do love, you're capable of changing the
entire universe because your love
expands outward and your love reflects
in other people as well. Okay. So Dante
uses the idea of mirrors.
There's a candle, there's a flame, and
we're all mirrors
that reflect
the candle. Okay? God, God is a candle.
We're just the mirrors.
But every one of us, no matter how far
we are from God, we
um the his flame burns in us. Okay?
So you could be far away and you could
feel as though God has forgotten you,
but there's still the flame inside you.
Okay? So for Dante and for our early
civilizations,
God is love forever. Okay? Eternal love.
But God is also eternal compassion,
eternal forgiveness. God will never
forgive you.
Sorry, God will never forget you. Okay?
He will always forgive you. But you have
to believe in God to return to God. You
have to live a life of righteousness, of
love, of compassion, of imagination. if
you want to return to God. Okay. So
that's how the universe is set up. We
are here, our divine mission is to
expand the consciousness of the
universe. And we do that by embracing
love and by imagining the world to be a
better place.
Okay. All right. So now let's go back
and ask ourselves this question. If
every single early religion, whether
it's Dowoism or Hinduism or the
Egyptians or the Native Americans, if
every early religion all believed this
and they all knew this, how did we come
to forget or deny this with a material
reality? Okay, remember the big bang,
evolution, neuroscience, it's to teach
us that there's no God, there's no
purpose, it's all just random, it's all
just material. So, how do we get this to
this point?
Okay,
the answer is very simple and we'll be
discussing this throughout CLA,
throughout the rest of the semester.
Okay. The problem is that you have
heaven,
you have earth,
and you have hell.
Okay?
The heaven is spiritual. It's
consciousness. Hell, it's mechanical.
It's machines.
Okay? We're stuck in between. It's
always our choice whether to choose
heaven or hell because of free will.
Okay? And for most of human history, we
have chosen
um heaven. But eventually you had people
who chose hell. And when you have choose
hell, you have access to technology,
right? And this technology allows you to
conquer and control other people.
Okay? But once you control and you
conquer and control other people, you
have to get them to obey you. If you are
enlightened, if you know the truth, you
know that none of this matters. We're
all we're all going to go. We're all
going to die. So why should I listen to
you? So in order for me to control you,
I need you to fear death.
Okay, I need you to forget God
and I need you to fear death. When you
die, dying is the worst thing that can
happen to you. And because remember
before people understood death was just
a part of the journey. It was a release.
It was an opportunity to reset yourself
and come back. Now death is the worst
thing that could ever happen to you.
Okay? So how do you forget God and how
do you uh get people to fear death? You
use science,
right? And you create theories like the
big bang, like evolution, like
neuroscience to forget to make people
forget the divinity inside
you.
Right? So that's what science is for.
But unfortunately
for these people that's not enough
because eventually we'll all die, right?
So the only way around this is by
creating a new technology called
transhumanism.
Okay, you may have heard of
transhumanism. Again, don't worry about
the concept now. We'll we'll discuss
this later on semester. But
transhumanism is to surpass humanity,
which basically means defeat death. To
upload you, your brain to the internet
so you're here forever.
Okay? To trap you here forever.
And so now the question then is
um why are they doing this? Why are
people in power doing this? Okay. So um
as we've discussed in this class
throughout human history it's usually
secret societies that have the power.
Okay.
Why? Okay. Well
we last class we discussed the idea of
bureaucracy right mass bureaucracy.
And we discussed how in a mass
bureaucracy bureaucrats don't really
want to do anything. They're lazy.
Well, guess what? If you're part of
secret society and you're able to
coordinate secretly together, you can
control the bureaucracy because you only
need people doing stuff. Okay?
But then the question, but the problem
is bureaucracies do not like secrets,
secret societies. So you have to
maintain your secrecy and and how do you
do that? You do that through
transgression.
If you guys are doing bad things
together, okay? Now you have blackmail
on each other and therefore you're
committed
to keeping each other's secrets. If one
of you falls down, everyone falls down
together. Okay? So now you're committed
to
um maintain a secrets. But the problem
is this. The problem is okay, it's
conspiracy, but the moment you're found
out, they'll come and arrest you. So how
do you work together without actually
meeting each other? And the answer is
religion.
Okay? Or the word we use is esquetology.
Religion is just a script and
understanding the world that allows you
to coordinate secretly. Okay. Does all
this make sense? Okay. So now these
secret societies, they are embedded in
mass bureaucracy and they're
manipulating the bureaucracy and they're
working together uh to commit
transgression. They have their own
secret religion. Okay. When you combine
these three together, what happens is
that they're now forced to invert.
This understanding inversion.
Why?
Because they know that they're doing
evil in this world. So when they go meet
God, God's going to punish them, right?
So the way to get around this is well I
will just c I will just worship someone
who's superior to God who is Satan.
Okay.
So what they're going to do is going to
invert this. Okay. By celebrating Satan,
they can now justify all their
transgressions, right? As a way to
empower Satan.
Also, there's a fundamental weakness in
the system. Okay, so let's go over the
three main characteristics of the
system. The first is unity.
Okay, so this entire system is complete
and unified. Second is symmetry.
symmetry or polarity.
And what this means is that if there's
good, there must be evil. If there's
ugliness, there must be beauty. Why?
Because you cannot have one without the
other. Okay? One thing is meaningless
without the other. That's why you have
God, you must have Satan. Okay? And the
third principle is
as above
so below. And what this means is that
everything is a reflection of each
other. So you can never defeat God. But
what you can do is corrupt human beings
to worship Satan so that Satan becomes
everything.
Okay.
All right. Are you guys following along?
Okay. So what you're trying to do is
you're trying to invert this world. And
how do you invert this world? What you
do is you know that hell is material and
you know that heaven is spiritual,
right? What you do is you brainwash
people to worship the material world and
abandon the spiritual world. You make
money,
>> power, technology, science the greatest
things in the world.
Okay? You get rid of God. You get a
religion. You get rid of compassion. You
get rid you get rid of love. And that's
how you control the
world. So in other words, what is
happening today is a war between heaven
and hell.
The people in charge, the secret
societies, they are interested. They
must make heaven in make hell into
heaven and heaven into hell. They must
invert the world in order to maintain
their power.
Okay? And that's what we will be
focusing on for the rest of the
semester. This war between heaven and
hell, how it came about, who are the
major players, and what will happen.
>> Yeah.
So I'm a bit confused about the part
where
um so the secret society
are manipulating their power beyond the
rest of the people and so they are
devoting themselves into the power of
Satan right but my question is so the
this God and Satan they don't interfere
they don't interfere to our world and so
these are all just decisions made by the
secret society itself.
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So if
well in that case if s say S Satan now
goes beyond or has the power that goes
be beyond God then God wouldn't do
anything to like rebut or something.
>> Yeah. Okay. Great. Great. Okay. So um
first thing to remember is that because
of the principle of free will God and
Satan cannot interfere in this world.
Okay. Secondly is we have to remember
like there are different secret
societies. There are thousands of
different secret societies. Okay. The
secret societies that are able to use
all three principles to accumulate power
on on are the most successful.
>> Okay. So that's why they're promoting
Satan.
Um then the third question then is
um
why doesn't God do doing anything about
this?
Okay. And the answer is
because if you think about it
in only in time of complete darkness
only when Satan rules
can humans fully shine.
Right? Does that make sense? So God has
trust in us. God has faith in us. God
loves us completely. God believes that
someone will stand up and do the right
thing.
And when that person does the right
thing, the universe will shine.
>> Okay? Does that make sense?
>> Right? So only in the time of darkness
can the light truly shine.
And remember when someone shines that
light, that light is reflected in
everyone else. So everyone's light
shines as well.
>> Okay? So that's the idea here.
You can choose to shine if you want, but
only if the world becomes really evil
and dark and sinful can you have this
option.
Okay. Yeah. Back back there.
>> Like is is there a really a god or a
Satan? And uh like uh there's a god for
all of it and uh a god for all of the
bad things or it's just two two worlds
which is one positive one negative.
>> Okay that's that's a really good
question. Okay so what all this is
saying is this. Okay in reality
literally everything is vibrations. All
right how these vibrations work right no
one knows but it's all just vibrational.
But what we know is we are participants
in the universe. So if we all believe
God exists, guess what? God exists. If
we all believe sin exists, sin exists.
Okay? That's why this war, it's not over
resources. It's over perception.
Do you understand? This is a war of
perception.
If I can get everyone in the world to
believe that God is dead and Satan is a
true God, I win.
Okay? And how do I do that? Well, I can
do that by shooting rockets up into
space by putting man on the moon and on
Mars. Okay? Why? Because now I destroyed
the concept of heaven. Before we've
understood that the moon, the Mars were
beyond us because they are heavenly.
They're spiritual. But once I put man on
the moon and on Mars and go beyond, I've
proven heaven doesn't exist. I've
destroyed God.
I can also fake an alien invasion
and pretend these aliens are Satan.
Okay.
Okay. All science, you you don't know
this, but all science, it's not about
discovering reality. It's about
reinventing reality in a way that serves
power. That's what science really is.
Yeah.
So is there people who like they they
don't believe in Satan or God? They
choose to let others believe in them
like uh they're making themselves into a
God. Does it work? Like because if you
believe God
uh then God exists like like if if
everyone believes in it. So if someone
make everyone believes in him or her uh
does does it work to make him into a god
or Satan some kind of
>> okay that's that's a good question and
the answer is no historically what's
happened is that a charismatic leader
has emerged to say that I am God's
representative
>> okay why because
um we believe we're all equal
right you're no different than I what
makes you God? Well, the answer is
because I'm channeling God.
>> Okay? And historically, so like like
look look at the early the early
empires, the early kingdoms. What what
they can say is that I'm descended from
God. God came down had sex with my
mother and now I'm born. Okay? But that
person is not saying you know I am God
itself but I am born of God.
>> Okay? Does that make sense?
>> Okay. All right. So this is the basic
framework for what what we we'll be
working with the rest of the semester.
Okay. But understand that what's
happening today is a war between heaven
and hell. If I can convince you that God
is dead and Satan is the true God. If I
if I can convince you that the material
world is real, the spiritual world is a
lie. If I can convince you
that death is the worst thing to happen
to you and you should do all you can to
live, then hell has won. Okay? But
what's important to understand is
this system is set up so that hell can
never win out. And the reason why is the
entire cosmos is interconnected.
So if we do evil, if we feel pain, if
there's too much suffering in the world,
the earth itself rebelss,
right? Because of vibrational energy and
this leads to things like the great
flood
which resets the world and lets humanity
renew itself. Okay. So, there are all
these different failsafe systems in
there in here to make sure that um hell
can never triumph and that's why Ellen
Mus is wants us to go to Mars. Okay. All
right. But understand you just use this
concept of heaven and hell even though
it's met metaphorical
even though God and Satan are just
projections of our imagination they do
help us understand the world better.
Okay. Okay. So, any questions? Any any
more questions before we we conclude for
today? Great. Okay. So, we'll continue
this tomorrow. Uh uh um Friday. Yep.
Okay.